[Music]
hi my name is Kristen and I may be drunk
okay
hi I'm shaquita and I may be drunk and
Katie and I may be drunk hi I'm jasmine
and I may be drunk hello my name is
Laura and I may be drunk today we're
gonna be put there today I'm gonna be
playing a game where I try to spot a
drunk person a telltale sign if someone
is drunk is that they will try and
convince you of how sober they are
they're a little wobbly but they're
always like you know trying to compose
themselves so usually I know this their
eyes going a little crisscross
applesauce maybe focusing a little bit
too much I feel like when you get that
like deep brow look they're probably
drunk why x-w be party i think d c ba
you missed q cy xw v UT s r QP o & l k j
i hg f DD
hahaha
z Y X W B I want to say oh yeah yeah
okay
Oh M I want to say hey L I kept the CBA
I feel like that was the whites
[Music]
I lost I'll go first
and our apparently insisted whatever I
touched first let's take out first rule
alright to the creators we have to honor
the rule you got it you got that's you
that's you that's you just rip it like a
band-aid well see cuz wait a minute now
oh wow
she's really getting in there I got a
kind of focus uh huh huh it's gonna be
me y'all it's all good I'm fine
Artie is doing nothing you know what
just for safety reasons yeah doing it
oh this takes a lot of coordination yeah
okay running gonna like I pulled over on
the chat okay I got one leg
oh my mom like my legs are like shaking
whoa oh no it's like so wobbly okay I do
this all the time
no I never ride in the way the main test
is once you go to the one foot I've
narrowed it down to two people I'm about
99.9% sure I know who the drug person
yeah I'm like 80% confident I'm gonna
give no percentages but I have a feeling
I have an idea I kind of narrowed it
down to two as well who I think great
minds think alike
mariachi duck fuzzy duck fuzzy duck
fuzzy duck fuzzy duck does he ducky fuzz
he fuzzy duck fuzzy duck fuzzy duck
fuzzy duck fuzzy duck fuzzy duck fuzzy
duck fuzzy duck does he ducky fuzz Oh
fuzzy duck fuzzy duck fuzzy duck fuzzy
duck does he fuzzy duck
[Laughter]
does he ducky fuzz ducky fuzz ducky fuzz
does he
huzi - fuzzy duck fuzzy duck fuzzy duck
fuzzy duck does he it's good judges
cough dang it
fuzzy duck fuzzy duck fuzzy duck does he
ducky fuzz ducky fuzz ducky fuzz ducky
fuzz does he I was down to two and it
was shaquita or Katy but I'm feel like
I'm sold more on shaquita now he was
just giggly impulsive I feel like when
you're drunk people are just over the
place and they lose their sometimes your
confidence
it made me possibly think you were drunk
but I've gotta go sometimes being drunk
brings on extreme joy lots of happiness
and I feel like one person here wow I
mean I kind of take that as a compliment
yeah I think that sometimes people who
are drunk like it brings out their
special talents so I feel like maybe
that's what happened for you
all right y'all I'm about to partake in
some libations I'm a drink Emma to set
when there ain't get much to come by uh
it's just a thing but you don't know
anything just say things confidently I'm
top-notch I told you earlier I'm Denzel
level I'm about to kill it I'm gonna
spot the drunk which is me but I'm not
gonna tell them that I'm actually the
drunk person
[Laughter]
[Music]